bonjour ça va bien vous
battant bien parce que moi je suis très
contente aussi
choqué quand même
pourquoi je pleure pas mais c'est pas du
tout à côté de mon chagrin pas du touch
suis pas du tout triste et c'est parce
que j'ai plus les oignons vous comprenez
sa petite lésion on peut pas s'empêcher
de pleurer je suis en train de préparer
une soupe à l'oignon
pour le dîner de casimir ce soir il fait
le plein de résistance et moi je dois
faire l'autre et c'est la première fois
que je préparais une une soupe à
l'oignon alors on va voir si elle émane
où l'eau
ça me pique mes de plus en plus et dire
que j'ai encore 5 kg elle plus chez
avoir excusé moi tout à l'heure
ça va durer encore longtemps ben tu
crois que je d'oeuvre se fait tout seul
toi c'est pas si tu fais un
chef-d'oeuvre mais moi je travaille
torticolis mais aussi ne bouge pas sans
arrêt ça fait deux heures que je pense
et alors la joconde a bien posé deux ans
elle pour léonard de vinci
je n'ai rien à son compte tu n'es pas
aller en un bar évidemment que je ne
suis pas léonard puisque léonard c'est
toi
[Musique]
on y compte décidément leonhardt que
trop nerveux je reprendrai la séance
demain je peux voir ce que tu as fait ah
bah si tu veux tu vas voir c'est très
très beau regarde c'est croissant blanc
un très joli mais
mais mais c'est moins sains a évidemment
jeté faire un peu plus beau que nature
mais dis moi pourquoi m'as-tu mis trois
yeux ben tu m'a toujours dit qu'il
fallait un oeil derrière la tête pour ne
pas être pris en traître mais oui c'est
une image tendance assez de la peinture
et pourquoi tu m'as pas la figure rouge
comme ça mais parce que parce que grougi
m'a fait voir rouge en se moquant de mon
tableau oui mais voir rouge temps bas
c'est seulement une façon de parler
ça veut dire être en colère c'est encore
une image je m'occupe pas d'image moi je
fais de la peinture
mais pourquoi tu as pas la peine guéri
bleus la prairie blue et ben ça c'est
parce que lorsque je n'avais plus de
verre mais pour obtenir du verre il
suffit de mélanger du vent légumes bleus
abou jaune et bleu ça fait vers et oui
et et rouge et bleu ça fait violet et
rouge et jaune ça fait orange mais c'est
magique
cmaj imminent il y a trois coups un
fondamental le jaune le rouge couple et
ses trois couleurs plus le blanc et
noirs on peut obtenir tous les autres
couleurs il suffit de faire des mélanges
alors moi j'ai acheté 9 10 pour rien et
je suppose que tu n'as plus d'argent
pour me payer les deux heures de pont ce
que tu veux toi non non ce n'est plus
rien du tout
on à mathieu martin laisse moi faire
monsieur martin monsieur martin venait
je viens de recevoir cette magnifique
coin abstraite mais comme je ne suis pas
un grand amateur en peinture je voudrais
la vendre ou d'échanger cette toile a
été peinte par mon grand ami touba vite
chauffe qui expose en ce moment aux
salons des farfelus indépendant
dieu mais ça sur mon goût la valeur vous
voulez combien cher ami martin je sais
que vous êtes un amateur sincère je me
contenterai donc 200 francs sens propre
poteau
voilà merci monseigneur merci
je crois que j'ai fait une bonne affaire
[Musique]
mais alors si tu as vendu ma peinture
c'est que j'ai du talent ou bien tu as
du talent ou c'est moi qui ai du génie
réfléchi et dans ma tête blonde mince un
[Musique]
bon jour julie
julie pleure à chaudes larmes je suis
allée la console et
julie tu es un gros chagrin
mais si julie tu pleures comme une
fontaine ah oui tu tu veux pas m'ennuyer
avec tes soucis tu sais ça fait du bien
parfois de se confier à un ami après on
y voit plus clair lors du rien de dire
non mais coûtent trop trois mois mon
mouchoir qu
il coûte filiger sais pas si je me
trompe mais j'ai l'impression que je
tends nuit
mais si ici tu penses que ton chagrin ne
nous concerne pas et que je suis très
indiscret en restant là plantée devant
toi bon écoute je vais je vais m'en
aller
j'espère que ce soir tu seras remise de
tes émotions au fait à quoi sera t-elle
ta soupe c'est une surprise
ah bon bon ben je file à ce soir même
julie est bizarre bonjour mon très cher
ami monsieur nous aider lance honneur
oui oui oui je vous conseille surtout de
passe via les impôts si manger rami sait
c'est l'heure de ma visite de courtoisie
nous viendra plus tard pour notre chère
julie qui se disent ah je veux saluer
quelles sont ses yeux rougis chez rémy
question ses larmes qui tels des perles
de cristal roule sur vos sous velouté et
à l'est par l'ombre du large enfin quels
sont ses plans enfin si nathan du vous
si heureuse d'habitude
mais je crois
que je viens de croiser venait bien
d'ici n'est ce pas
c'est donc lui le responsable de ses
larmes
d'habitude un garçon si convenable et
voulait m'empêcher de venir voir le
résultat de ces tracasseries à votre
égard mais je vais aller le berger
messieurs non non pas du tout vous me
retenait dans un grand élan de
générosité c'est beau chercher il vaut
mieux pour lui parce que j'aurais donné
une correction est venu pour moi aussi
parce que françois est un garçon sportif
est costaud monsieur du snal oui
c'est sûr leurs amis et bien vilaine ici
que je filmais ça c'est clair non mais
non ce fil
et à moi c'est pas fini pleuré j'ai
encore trois kilos d'oignons à éplucher
à bonjour
aujourd'hui je n'ai pas une minute à moi
je dois préparer un plat pour le dîner
de ce soir j'aurais faire une délicieuse
tarte à l'oignon
j'adore les oignons d'ailleurs j'ai
ramassé tout ce qui restait dans mon
jardin lorsque j'ai annoncé à ma tante
adélaïde elle m'a donné un truc pour ne
pas pleurer en les épluchant elle m'a
dit qu'il fallait les éplucher sous
l'eau
voilà comme ça ça ira
quant à mon cousin albéric il m'a donné
un deuxième conseil il m'a dit qu'il
fallait verser dessus une pensée de
sucre en poudre 1
voilà
et comme trois conseils valent mieux qu
2 j'ai suivi le conseil de mon oncle
archibald qui lui m'a dit qu'il fallait
absolument éplucher les oignons dans un
sac en plastique
voilà
ceci dit j'ai moi même trouvé une
quatrième solution
beaucoup plus efficace ça j'aurais
demandé à leonardo les éplucher pour moi
il y en a je t'envoie des oignons et
plus moi ça tout de suite
oui je me demande bien ce que nous de
cuisinier nous ont préparé et coûté en
tout cas j'ai une bonne nouvelle je suis
passé par le potager de casimir il n'y a
plus un sens l'oignon ne mangeront donc
pas ce soir
à lyon
et pour aux tables on voulait dire est
souvent stable en tout cas je me demande
pourquoi se mettaient à julie était si
triste oui moi aussi assez bien
malheureux à ça nous gâchent notre
soirée et dire que je vous avais
justement accusé d'être la cause de ses
larmes à la
salle entendu je n'en parlons plus
voyant
mon plat et presque cuit
je crois que nous allons nous régaler à
julie n'est pas encore là non
malheureusement ce n'est pas la rue au
rhum à cher ami quelle surprise
mais si julie mais ton chagrin
vos larmes
mais je n'avais pas de chagrin j'épluche
et les oignons pour ma soupe et comme
c'était une surprise je ne pouvais pas
me dire
des à lyon
pour une surprise
vous n'aimez pas la soupe à l'oignon
aussi ici d'habitude moi les miens
j'aime beaucoup ça mais ça fait déjà
quatre fois que casimir nous sert des
oignons l'ail alors
eh bien tant pis commençons par le plat
principal
oui ah mais non non non attendez moi moi
j'ai à perdre à soupe à l'oignon alors
je la mange ray on dessert
de la soupe à l'oignon en dessert et
s'il aime ça c'est son droit casimir si
vous êtes cuisinier l'arrière là ça
vient
une délicieuse à quaregnon n'y aura non
non non pt alors tu avais attendez ne
partez pas emmener pour vous consoler je
vais vous chanter ma chanson ah bon
alors en revanche en sont d'accord la
nôtre et c'est très triste
[Musique]
habitude chantons
imagination
je vous emmène dans notre île au sommet
du bonheur tranquille
[Musique]
ne soyez pas terrorisé
je suis le monstre du berry
je m'appelle casini
j'ai la boule orange
donc
si l'on me
voit
je sais jouer de la vessie
je suis gay et smalling amis si j'aime
la glace au choix c'est pourquoi raymond
droit
ravis que de chansons
un peu d'imagination
je vous emmène dans notre idée du
bonheur tranquille
ces coûts peuvent rencontrer
ne soyez pas terrorisé
je suis le monstre qui fait rire
je m'appelle casimir
j'ai une malle magique
est puni des ventes à sting je mange du
cloud bi pour le cabinet jeune
femme a
gémi à la campagne j'ai vu le rideau
montagnes aux cimes et même au cas où
c'est mon droit
au droit
avec une chanson
imaginez
[Musique]
so many dans notre île
tant pis
il a compris
ne soyez pas trop
je suis le bon ce qui fait rire
je m'appelle casini
[Musique]